what are you going to have I think it
would get um dumplings
hot and sour soup
a nice bowl of soup on a cold day there
you go
I spill the soup on a cold day but they
are just
so and during it's just couldn't you
have just pictured Pelosi they were
obviously at a Chinese restaurant just
turning to the waiter and being like
number four number four Diet Coke
that's your fried rice
that's not racist people it's a joke
people have been doing that joke it's an
old joke if you think it's racist then
you're upset be upset with some comedian
in 1986 don't be upset with me you
should be upset with the pandering from
the Democrats I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's December 21st 2022
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and Blaze TV subscribe if you haven't
and today people as we roll in to the
end of the year man our politicians are
going out in a blaze of BS the swamp is
swamping just absolute insanity is
happening in America right now we're
actually going to put aside some of the
Twitter stuff and the Free Speech stuff
uh today because uh Vladimir zielinski
from Ukraine he is here he is in America
today apparently this is his first uh
his first international trip since this
war not war started and he's giving a
speech to both sessions of the house
tonight and
a little something my eyes here I'm
crying because the number four
um he's uh he's talking to Congress
tonight and he's going to be asking for
a whole bunch more cash and he's getting
a whole bunch more cash because as you
may have heard this absolutely
completely insane 4
000 page Omnibus Bill which was given to
all of our politicians basically
yesterday will be voted on today uh and
nobody read it
nobody read it Rand Paul carded it out
he printed the whole thing that's an
awful lot of paper and you know printer
ink as you guys know in this office
printering is extremely expensive people
don't know this printer ink I think is
cost more than gas and oil like per
liter or whatever it is however they
measure printer ink that's how expensive
printer ink is so Rand Paul spent a lot
on printering
these people are just spending our money
like drunken Sailors they are printing
money this is both sides of the aisle
okay it's it's all the Democrats but
it's most of the Republicans too uh
there are a couple who are standing up
against it obviously Rand Paul is the
main one but Ted Cruz is to some degree
Kevin McCarthy is and the house will get
into all of that but really what the
focus of the show is as we wrap up the
year here today is that there is a lot
of work to be done because even though
as I try to always spin things
positively we have these pockets of
sanity and freedom and fiscal
responsibility and all of those things
obviously Florida I would say is Central
to that at the federal level Everything
Is Broken
and you don't have to be a republican
but you can't be a Democrat sure but the
Republicans will fail you all the time
too and today is going to be an
exploration of that because what these
clowns are are doing with our money as
we have no money and they're given more
money to the NIH and more money to the
FBI and more money to Ukraine and
everything else it's like man have you
guys learned nothing and I guess they
did learn nothing because we don't vote
them out so that's what we're doing
today how are you okay here we go so
zelenski from Ukraine now he was a
former comedian and a television host
became uh the president of Ukraine uh
he's a big star now if we've learned
anything in this last year the man is a
big star so we thought we'd start before
we get to the nitty-gritty and the nuts
and bolts of the money and the scale of
the war and all that stuff we thought
we'd go through some of the the stardom
that this guy has attained over the last
year or so here he is you may remember
this one when he met Ben Stiller in
Ukraine earlier this year and you would
imagine as a guy going through this
horrific war and people are being killed
and fleeing the country and bombs are
dropping everywhere that you might not
have time to meet Zoolander but this guy
worked it out hello
thanks for taking the time
[Music]
it's a great honor for me and nice to
see you
um
it's really wonderful you're my hero yes
as a if you quit a great acting career
for this not so great with you no but
pretty great um but what you've done in
the way that you've rallied the country
and what you know for the world it's
really inspiring so the level of
Destruction I mean you see it on
television exactly what you're saying
you see it on TV you see it on social
media
and you you know it's something else to
actually
see it and feel it it's so perfect Ben
Stiller You're My Hero there is zero
chance that Ben Stiller knew who
zielinski was last year again they are
in the midst of this what we're told is
this really horrific war in the country
is collapsing but they have time to sit
down and chat with a comedian and you
know what's going on how you doing
you're a great actor I'm a great actor
let's go through the shtick it's just
such silliness and by the way if if he
had anything of value to say if there
was any reason like true reason to help
Ukraine that Ben Stiller was there they
wouldn't be doing it in front of cameras
they would be having private meetings
but the idea that they have to make the
show of everything that seems to meet to
me to be where we're at with almost
everything at this point The Show Must
Go On it's not really what's happening
in the world what level of Destruction
there is what's really going on in
Ukraine it's that The Show Must Go On
speaking of the show uh zielinsky also
managed to go on David Letterman a
couple months ago and a bomb apparently
was flying by the uh the area where they
were filming so they had to stop for a
second because of the sirens and
zielinski explained that to Dave what
was the siren indicating
is
yeah they're so accustomed to them that
David didn't have to get out of his
chair don't worry about that they're
also in a in a train station there that
they've lit beautifully looks like a
Hollywood set they're ignoring bomb
Sirens like is anyone paying attention
to any of this but the show must go on
as I said and here you see during the
Grammys uh zielinski appeared and he
spoke to the good people of Hollywood I
want musicians wear body armor instead
of tuxedo they seem to their wounded in
hospitals even to those who can't hear
them but the music will break through
anyway we defend our freedom to live to
love to sound on our land we are
fighting Russia which brings horrible
Silence with its bombs the Dead Silence
feel the Silence with your music fill it
today to tell our story did I hear that
correctly did he just say that musicians
in body armor sing to deaf people in
their hospitals somehow the music gets
through
he is an actor okay here's a little more
from the Grammys John Legend and a
Ukrainian Refugee which was the title of
my first band when I was years ago in
Brooklyn I was called John Legend and
the Ukrainian refugees
um singing about Ukraine at the Grammys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
shoot and protect my husband my parents
my child and my mother and
it's a show guys it's a show by the way
I just you know I know I'm being a
little tongue-in-cheek with some of this
stuff I'm not denying that Russia is
bombing the hell out of Ukraine as this
says has demolished the lives of
hundreds of thousands of people as a
matter of fact locals had an office in
Ukraine that we don't have anymore and
several of our employees we were able to
help get them out I can't explain
exactly how we did it for obvious
reasons but some of them are now in the
United States and actually we're at our
uh our holiday party at my house a
couple days ago so uh this is not to say
that I have no sympathy for the people
of Ukraine but something else is going
on here at this level right there the
people are all at this level but the
machine and the way it operates and the
fakery and the show and all of that
that's up here and that's what I'm
poking fun at right now uh here is
zielinski and his wife posing for a
Vogue photo shoot again one of these
things you would imagine at the height
of a war you have a lot to do like guys
could we move the soldiers this way do
we have enough bullets uh but you know
vote photo shoot
foreign
[Music]
you may have recognized famous portrait
photographer Annie Leibovitz there she's
the one that took care of that and again
it's just like if you were real like try
to imagine say I don't know Winston
Churchill
Winston Churchill the Nazis are on the
way guys the Nazis are coming excuse me
I'm trying to take a picture for Vogue
okay
how was that for a Churchill
impersonation I'm trying to take a
picture for Vogue just a second
ridiculous anyway the meme makers of the
internet had a little fun with that so
take a look
[Music]
God woman scares me anyway uh zielinski
also became Time magazine's person of
the year look at him like a Star Wars
character everything is this is what
they do with everything now right it's
one big face and then Small Faces around
it just like he is from Revenge of the
Sith oh lordy lordy okay so why am I
telling you all of this because I want
to show you first the show portion of
all of this this man is under no threat
he is obviously not worried he is not
starving he is meeting celebrities he's
talking to the Grammys he's in it with
Hollywood he's getting a [ __ ] ton right
that's a technical term of cash his wife
can you confirm the number on this for
me I'm fairly certain went to Paris last
week and spent forty thousand dollars on
jewelry and bags we just will get the
confirmation on that thing uh but yes uh
zielinski is uh is meeting with
everybody you may remember this uh
remember we're in the middle of a war in
Ukraine for some reason all of our
politicians can just show up there
nobody's wearing helmets nobody he's
worried they're going to get bombed
here's Mitch McConnell in his tan pants
just showing up and saying hi to
zielinski
Hello nice to meet you
thank you thank you so much
thank you sir thank you we know each
other a little bit yeah
foreign
as you can see guys the threat of War
because you know Mitch McConnell if
there was a war and people you know he
sends a lot of people to war and he
likes putting a lot of money into war
but he often doesn't go to the war zones
right so you could see he was really
freaked out you know with the slacks and
the pictures and the whole thing uh yeah
okay Zippity Dippity uh anyway uh
zielinski is slated to speak to Congress
tonight we have a video previewing some
of that Vladimir zielinski is going to
leave Ukraine for the first time since
the war started and come to speak to a
joint meeting of Congress in the house
chamber tomorrow night you might
remember that zielinski spoke to a joint
meeting of Congress virtually in
mid-march of this year this is the first
time that he has left Ukraine he left
Ukraine to go to Munich just for a few
days before the war started there was a
cryptic message that was sent by house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi just about an hour
ago to her members she wants members to
come back to Washington to vote for the
Omnibus spending bill and I thought that
this message was a little bit strange
because they have remote voting in the
House of Representatives and not
everybody would need to be here in
person to cast their ballots and it says
this is the message from Pelosi we are
ending a very special session of the
117th congress with legislation that
makes progress for the American people
as well as support for democracy please
be present for a very special Focus
Wednesday night
okay so there's something interesting
that he's saying there at the end we're
going to get to the spending bill in
just a second and wait so I mean some of
this stuff is just absolutely insane you
have to understand these people vote
electronically usually they vote
remotely barely anyone shows up in DC
when we were in DC a couple weeks ago
it's a freaking ghost town it's it's
disturbing what it's like over there uh
and we were there right after the
election when actually there were a few
people there but there's just no regular
people there's government people couple
government people but the stores are
empty the the restaurants are empty et
cetera Etc she wants everybody to come
back because somehow her master
zielinski I don't know I don't know who
the master is who's bones rings but
somehow you got to come back to listen
to zielinski the guy we're giving a ton
of money to we have no money we have
printed a lot of money and destroyed our
economy here in the United States but we
got to keep giving money to Ukraine and
we'll get some of those numbers for you
in just a second here's a bit more from
The Daily Item Congressional leaders
unveiled a government-wide
1.7 trillion spending package or early
Tuesday that includes another large
round of Aid to Ukraine a nearly 10
percent boost in defense spending and
roughly 40 billion in emergency spending
mostly to assist communities across the
country recovering from drought
hurricanes and other natural disasters
the bill which runs for
4155 Pages includes about
772.5 billion for non-defense
discretionary programs and 858 billion
for defense and would last through the
end of the fiscal year at the end of
September lawmakers worked to stuff as
many priorities as they could into the
sprawling package likely the last major
bill of the current Congress they are
racing to complete a passage before a
midnight Friday deadline or face the
prospect of a partial government
shutdown going into the Christmas
holiday lawmakers leading the
negotiations released the details of the
bill shortly before 2A a.m on Tuesday so
let's just be real clear about how the
government operates and by the way guys
the government has always operated this
way but with the cacophony of insanity
that we are all up against with these
people and all of the things we're
finding out through Twitter leaks and
all of the censorship We have dealt with
and everything else the idea that at 2
A.M on Tuesday they're releasing a 4 000
page Bill and everyone's going to vote
on it the next day it's absolutely
insane I would bet my life literally my
life that zero of these people who will
vote on this thing have have read it in
totality zero literally not one of them
this is what they do with everything and
by the way they don't have to do this
right they don't have to do this we're
going to show you in a video in a second
they're allowed to just fund the
government for the rest of the year and
figure it out but they're doing it
knowing Christmas is coming people don't
want to look like the Grinch I'm such a
good politician I'm spending more of the
people's money for the people
look at me uh we've got a little info
here from the center for strategic and
international studies on what's going on
with this money related to Ukraine U.S
Aid to Ukraine total 68 billion and the
White House has just asked Congress for
another
37.7 billion in the spring the new
Congress will consider Aid in the
context of the administration's proposed
fiscal year 2024 budget with these
decisions ahead it is worth reviewing
how much Aid there has been what the aid
does and what the administration is
requesting such a review turns up some
surprises and will help clarify
discussions about future Aid packages
you guys may remember that we had Rand
Paul on when they passed the last
version of Ukraine Aid and all Rand Paul
was asking for were receipts right he
wasn't thrilled with giving them more
money he's a Libertarian he's more of an
isolationist generally speaking but he
wasn't actually completely against
anything as far as I could tell but all
he said was hey we're going to give them
a whole bunch of money could we see what
they're doing what are you guys doing
with the money with the money are you
buying sweatshirts are you buying
weapons are you buying video games are
you buying crack like what the hell is
going on here crack is likely because
you know under Biden anyway listen to
Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell I don't
know how many times I've even mentioned
Mitch McConnell in the years that we've
been doing the direct message I barely
talk about this guy he looms large over
Washington obviously he's he's part of
the swamp he is he is really I mean just
watch this and tell me that this is how
you feel making sure the defense
department can deal with the major
threats coming from Russia and China
providing assistance for ukrainians to
defeat the Russians that's the number
one priority for the United States right
now
according to most Republicans that's
sort of how we see the
challenges confronting the country at
the moment
hiding assistance to make sure Ukraine
can defeat the Russians is number one on
Republicans Minds I have to say I'm a
newly minted Republican I registered as
a republican we got down here to Florida
giving more money to Ukraine is not in
my top 20. got her top 20. Phoenix top
20 Daphne top 20.
so Daphne went like this so we're going
to say it's 19 on Daphne's but that's
still pretty low nobody wants to do this
except you evil sucking swamp creatures
you're the only people who want to do
this it is not the top of anyone's mind
how about the economy how about the
Border how about Free Speech we could go
through a whole bunch of stuff here
just awful but he's so proud he's so
proud they've been able to jam through
another spending bill with money they
don't have that's how good he is at his
job
so admittedly I'm pretty
proud of the fact that with the
Democratic president Democratic house
and Democratic Senate
we were able to achieve through this
Omnibus spending bill
essentially all of our priorities
what priorities and who do you mean by
our our priorities I don't think you
mean the people's priorities because I
do not know anyone that thinks that
funding Ukraine anymore to defeat Russia
whatever you think defeat means and by
the way when you get pretty close to
defeating the guy with nukes he might do
something crazy which is kind of what
I'm starting to think all you people
want because you're losing control at
such a rapid rate and so many people are
waking up so fast that you're kind of
like ah let's get a nuclear war going
because that'll distract everybody and I
wouldn't put anything past these people
uh here's Chuck Schumer and Mitch is
very happy to work with Chuck it's odd
they hate each other on everything
they're always fighting but when it
comes to spending all of our money and
getting us more in debt and doing things
that will do no good for anyone and
helping a comedian actor in Ukraine hang
out with Ben Stiller and David Letterman
then they agree and they really love
each other it's really fantastic here's
Chuck Schumer being asked well could is
it possible that anyone even read this
freaking thing
underpaid bill this morning expect to
vote on it tomorrow but most of Congress
hasn't had a chance to review look the
bill has been carefully worked on by the
Appropriations Committee for a very very
long time most of the provisions of the
bill were well known weeks and weeks and
weeks in advance and getting this bill
done for the American people which
really matters is the most important
thing yes got everything he says is live
first off this does nothing for the
American people this will make
everything worse for the American people
he is not for the American people
McConnell is not for the American people
if I'm an American you you people have
nothing to do with any of the things
that I believe in and man the swamp has
to be drained like they're making more
of an argument for Trump than Trump can
make for himself that's really what's
going on here it's incredible what these
people are doing uh also this idea that
it was bounced around the Appropriations
Committee so everyone knew what was in
it you know it's funny I am a I would
say I'm a fairly astute person when it
comes to watching the news and I pay
attention to these things I'm on Twitter
I have a phone in my hand all the time I
never saw any of this stuff why didn't
any of this stuff get leaked remember
when Roe vaid decision that thing got
leaked we never found out who leaked it
that's kind of weird but everything gets
leaked everything is leaked to the New
York Times but somehow all of the
spending that didn't get leaked until
they released it at 2 A.M that's what
they do and also a 2 A.M Tuesday release
you know who else does that when Google
and Apple update your terms of service
and they tell you subtly that you're
going to lose some rights or some free
speech or some ability to do something
they're going to do something Shady or
they're going to track you you know what
time they do it 2 A.M on Tuesdays that's
pretty much how this thing works anyway
here's Joe manchin who people think of
as a somewhat sane guy and occasionally
is despite being a Democrat uh here he
is going after Kevin McCarthy because
Kevin McCarthy's actually trying to
stand his ground on this thing and say
hey guys let's fund the government for
the rest of the year but let's not sign
off on this crazy bill so credit where
it's due McCarthy's trying to do the
right thing mansion who Republicans
usually think is pretty decent uh well
take a look I don't know if you saw but
Kevin McCarthy who is really trying to
get the votes to become speaker he said
that if any Republicans in the Senate
vote for this Omnibus spending Bill 1.7
trillion dollars then
their legislative priorities will not be
heard in the house when he is Speaker
Mitt Romney called that uh silliness
what do you think of it I think
described it pretty well yeah pretty
well I mean this is not a vindictive
type of thing that we're not in we're
not in high school or college and
playing games back and forth this is
real life yeah it's real life so
actually McCarthy is doing the right
thing he's saying let's not do this just
because it's Christmas and we want to go
on vacation let's fund the government
for the rest of the year and then figure
it out when we Republicans have more
power literally in about two weeks from
now okay just on the other side of the
new year that's when this all will
change but instead uh you've got well
Mitt Romney doesn't like him and then of
course Joe manchin likes Mitt Romney
it's like Mitt Romney's nothing Mitt
Romney is a Democrat like don't you see
it these people and also these aren't
these we can't play these games of
course McCarthy's doing the right thing
you should punish your guys who behave
like basically like drunken Sailors like
a bunch of drunken Democrats you should
punish them if you guys vote for this
you're basically wrecking a somewhat
let's say sane Republican agenda and
McCarthy should punish you he absolutely
should I'm with you McCarthy on that for
sure uh all right so some Republicans
are actually speaking up uh and I've
sort of been laying it out for you but
here's Kevin McCarthy on what he would
do right now voters have voted to change
the Republicans would be in power in 15
days so why wouldn't we simply do a
continuing resolution fund the
government into the next year and then
we'd have an opportunity to actually cut
spending they are going to increase
they're going to increase by more than
100 billion dollars after all the
increases they've done for so now the
Baseline when we take over is going to
be a hundred billion dollars more adding
more to inflation these two senators
Leahy and Shelby won't have to face the
voters because they're leaving they
won't even tell us what the numbers are
and they're going to show a bill that
are thousands of pages that nobody can
read and then what the Democrats did was
to pass the continuing resolution right
up to Christmas and pressure us to pass
this bill which is wrong we should hold
on and let Republicans help us secure
the Border in funding this government
the Republicans are about to have some
power as he said in 15 days the
Republicans are about to be able to do
some things and all of these sellouts
Mitt Romney and all the rest of them
they are going to sign this thing that
the thing's going to pass like it's just
it is what it is it's entropy the
government constantly works with entropy
it just moves and moves and moves and
moves and a bunch of us try to fight it
and you can get little wins here and
there but the thing just moves right but
McCarthy's absolutely right get us to
the end of the year we'll take over and
then
we could do this
we can rip the freaking thing up and we
could figure out other ways to fund
things instead of just endlessly
spending and funding the war and funding
these agencies that have worked against
us the American people and everything
else
but you know there are one or two sane
people in government but I usually put
Rand Paul at the top of my list and uh
yeah Rand Paul's not happy about it I
brought with me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released now people argue that it's
conservative's fault it's you don't have
the Christmas spirit somehow you're
holding up government well whose job is
it to produce this the people in charge
of spending the people in charge of both
of the parties when did they know that
this would be necessary well it's in the
law September 30th you got nine months
almost 10 months to produce a plan to
have a spending plan they weren't ready
on September 30th so they voted
themselves 90 more days they weren't
ready last week either so they voted
themselves another week and now we have
it at 1 30 in the morning this morning
but what's the clamor the clamor's to
vote vote now let's get it done why are
you standing in the way of spending
well the real question is this what is
more dangerous what is more dangerous to
the country
1.1 trillion dollars in new debt or is
Republican leadership likes to say oh
but it's a win it's a big win we're
getting 45 billion dollars for the
military so which is more important
which threatens the country more are we
at risk for being invaded by a foreign
power if we don't put 45 billion into
the military Are we more at risk by
adding to a 31 trillion dollar debt
I think the greatest risk to our
national security is our debt the
process stinks it's an Abomination it's
a no-good rotten way to run your
government
you know what's interesting is that
Mitch McConnell as you know is from
Kentucky
Rand Paul as you know is from Kentucky I
have a feeling these guys don't have
dinner that often
um yeah everything that Rand Paul said
there is true the way they frame
everything the time they have to do it
and then they try to jam it through and
nobody's read it and they send it to you
late and all of that stuff you know I I
obviously I like Rand Paul a lot and I
saw him in DC a couple weeks ago and we
interviewed him again
um it's interesting because and I've
sort of tried to say this to him
sometimes it's like he's kind of like
the sane guy who accidentally got thrown
into the mental institution right so
everyone in DC Republicans who they're
all just awful everyone does all the
wrong things like they just don't care
nobody nobody is willing to take the
slings and hours and I'm talking at the
federal level because obviously I'm not
talking about the state level where
there are good things working Florida
um
but he's the guy who they accidentally
admitted to the mental institution and
he's trying to tell everybody guys guys
I'm not supposed to be here there's ways
better we can do this thing we don't
have to drug everybody we should try
some other therapies there's you know
okay and I know this guy's talking to
himself and this guy's whatever and but
and and he just but he's a glutton for
punishment but he's he's basically like
one man standing there as the tide gets
higher and higher going guys we're all
going to drown soon does anyone does
anyone want to get some flip-flops or
what do they call those things little
little things that go on the kids arms
not little floaties thank you uh here
here's a picture that Rand Paul tweeted
out that's the size of the bill
4155 Pages nobody has read that freaking
thing all right so what is this all what
does this all get us to so look
zielinski is going to come he's going to
walk out with a ton of cash the war in
Ukraine will continue the government
will be funded we're going to give all
of this money to just like crazy things
it's like 70 million to to study salmon
here it's like all of the crazy crazy
things like think of something crazy
we're probably funding it you know and
and he makes a good point it's like okay
so like personally I'm for a strong
military I am for a strong military so
that you don't have to use it right the
idea is that you have some level of
deterrence so I'm not against funding
the military but he's right it's not as
if we're going to be invaded next week
so why don't you unless you guys know
something I don't know but it's like why
don't you just wait guys just show some
freaking in balls you just got the house
back and you show some balls or do they
have your balls how did they get your
balls
but you want to talk about a guy with
balls there's a guy with balls he's
right here in Florida his name's Ron
DeSantis he's the governor have you
heard about him uh he's running the
state incredibly well biscally well
uh legally well philosophically well
with the right ideas the right set of
values all of those things uh and he
gave a talk yesterday you know because
we're still in the midst of this this
cleanup from this unbelievably basically
category five hurricane that hit
Southwest Florida so we're in the midst
of this cleanup FEMA pulled out money
Florida made up for it we've we've
rebuilt roads we've rebuilt houses
communities faster than anyone could
have possibly imagined and the governor
was asked about his sort of philosophy
around how you do good things and and
really that it's not just about one man
station and we've been able to I think
attract a lot of really really good
people and people who when you're in
these positions you know these are folks
that are really dedicated to the cause
and um and it's important because you
know you can have great policy you can
have a great vision because you got to
have people there that believe in it are
going to implement it and not try to
undermine it or undercut it and so we've
had great buy-in and we've had a lot of
people that have really put the mission
first and I think that's part of the
reason you know we've been so successful
I mean I can sit here and do the press
conferences and I'll get more cameras
than some of the other people who work
in state government but you know if I
had to build the bridge by myself
without having people who were willing
to get in there and and heed our
directives and really work hard to
implement our vision you know it
wouldn't have happened as quickly as
that so all that's very very important
and I think we've created a very
positive culture of a can-do spirit
and isn't that something like in stark
contrast to McConnell McConnell just the
tone with which he talks the number one
priority for republicans in America is
keeping Ukraine safe against Russia and
it's like actually you know there's an
awful lot of Republicans down in South
Florida for example who want their
Bridges rebuilt want their communities
back up and running want to get their
stores going on electricity and
everything else and what's really good
about what the scientists is doing
they're saying I'm gonna get the cameras
no matter what I can't do this I can
give speeches I can respond to reporters
but we need good people there and what's
also interesting a little subtext to
that he said we will attract good people
and it's not that you just have to
believe in the vision you have to
implement it and it's like it's actually
happening because people are moving here
good people are moving here and bringing
skills and bringing their families and
their values and it's happening here so
it's working at a certain state level
but the federal thing Man it is freaking
effed up and Solinski is just gonna walk
out of here with cash and remember FEMA
cut the aid to Florida right they cut
the aid to Florida it was I think 25
million dollars it's not much Florida
made it up
but we're going to give this guy a
couple more billions what 37 more
billion after the 68 we've given him
already and it's like are we winning the
war is this doing anything for American
interest Putin's not a good dude that
it's not good to invade your neighbors
and every country has a right to defend
itself but what in the high hell are we
doing here and if the Republicans have
not learned at this point that people
want them to stand up against this this
is the thing that people want them to
stand up for that as I said earlier
they're doing Trump's job for them
because the average person is going to
go wait a minute we can either have
these McConnell types and fund crazy
Wars and spend all this money we don't
have or Trump and he doesn't he's not
even on Twitter anymore so we don't have
to worry about the Mean Tweets that's
that's the situation that they're laying
out there guys stick around for a cold
close couple comments from the Reuben
report dot locals.com Community
Elizabeth says why can we pump as much
money as possible into Ukraine to defend
democracy but the same people can't the
same people get mad when we help Israel
this is this is endless you know it's so
interesting because to me I would if you
were asking me what would you do right
so I've been complaining about what
these people do how about we just cut
the entire federal budget and I mean
across the board I mean Federal foreign
spending defense spending cut
departments get rid of the department I
would Department of Education Department
of everything Transportation cut
everything by 25 how about we do that
and we say we're going to cut everything
by 25 for six months and see what
happens
right how about that could we do that
and see what happens and guess what
everything would be just fine and as a
matter of fact I suspect things would be
a lot better but they can't do that
because they're on the gravy train and
they can't do it and uh that that's the
problem
uh Martin King says I'd be quite happy
if the government were to shut down
there are certain critical functions
that never shut down so what's the
problem right that is also a funny point
you know the I first off the idea that
the government was shut down all right
go ahead federal government shut down
I'll be all right
we could go bowling later or something
you know we haven't been bowling in a
while that would be fun shut down we
don't need you in a weird way that's why
they very rarely shut down when was the
last government shutdown can you check
on that I remember one maybe in the was
it
2019 so we did do like a temporary one
for a couple days it's like let the
government shut down Okay the reason
that they don't want the government to
shut down is because after three days
you might be like
what do we need those guys for you know
so they have to keep funding the
nonsense so that we think that we need
it uh guys if you have not subscribed
please do it rumble.com
reubenreport and join us if you want to
live chat during the show and much more
at reubenreport.locals.com uh by the way
uh Friday will be our last show of the
year we've got a couple year-end shows
and best dubs and everything else coming
out Christmas but we're not you know
Christmas week but we're not going to
bludgeon you with a ton of stuff we'll
have a bunch of announcements on Friday
oh and uh we are going to announce one
of the announcements on Friday will be
that yes we are moving we're helping
somebody move from Cali likely to
Florida that's the idea we've got a
whole bunch of people that have
resubmitted their stories on locals and
we are going to pick somebody and we're
going to throw in some cash and I'll see
what I can do pay for a moving truck
this that the other thing we'll figure
it out
um so stay tuned for that on Friday
we leave you we didn't say his name once
during the show today with the elderly
man pretending to be president
look uh and I want to thank a good
friend of mine
Michigan governor
Gretchen Whitmer you've got a backbone
like a ramrod you know and of course
I know you've had an incredible role
model in America Lance bottoms she's got
a backbone like a ramrod the vice
president of the United States Vice
President Harris how's she doing you're
almost two years in she's doing great
she has a backbone like a ramrod but the
truth is she's the strongest person I
know she's a backbone like a ramrod I
see the world where I grew up like many
of you I grew up in Scranton as I said
my mom taught me
my mom had a backbone like a ramrod